hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
before we get the chance to play the new
god of war aka Kratos the dad simulator
I thought we should go back in time and
look at some of the brutal kills Kratos
has dished out over the years keep in
mind he's a vengeful bugger a warrior of
death and destruction because his wife
and daughter were killed so cut him a
little slack and expect to see a lot of
digital blood
oh and remember spoilers incoming so if
you haven't played the games then come
back a little later okay let's do this
in God of War three Kratos finds himself
battling Hermes the messenger of the
gods who possesses lightning speed and
reactions you don't try to catch me
because you know you can Kratos where
are you off to today Hermes the little
goblet evades Kratos for quite some time
until
[Music]
come on hermie I'm no doctor but you can
walk that off
I always thought Kratos was a bit of a
leg and legend like
in God of War ascension Kratos comes up
against Pollux and castor
these Siamese twins didn't really have
much of a chance and during a fall to
their certain death kratos decided to
perform surgery on the twins
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as mr. swats [ __ ] would say at the
split it's not over yet one brother
miraculously survived kratos is on hand
to sort things out I thought I did
really well there yeah yeah he really
crushed it
after all he would have sparked after
all you have sacrificed it ends in I
love her stunning failure when Kratos
and his father Zeus who so happens to be
the king of the gods
battled to the death few would have
expected a third combatant thrown into
the mix but he is Gaia 300-foot on
earthly rage here to take out father and
son the fight ends up in Gaius chest
right in front of her heart
allowing crate off to take out both in
one fell swoop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
guy is gone but Zeus isn't finished yet
but Kratos is in full Rocky Balboa mode
now slugging and bells and [ __ ] out of
its bother there is so much blood at
this point that the entire screen fills
up with Pinzon
[Music]
one badly time trophy later and
retribution is yours
what a lovely father-and-son moment
another family member Kratos has
murdered hello brother this is a little
brother Hercules well Hercules is known
for his strength which leads to his
downfall
Kratos takes down his bro who looks a
lot like The Incredible Bull and makes
his face so messed up it would scare the
crap out of the toilet
well that's the end of that bromance
facade and is next on our list in an
epic fight Kratos shouldn't really stand
a chance of winning here but he finds a
way to dislodge the god of the sea
[Music]
now man against man Kratos has the upper
hand but is the camera angle used which
makes this one particularly grotesque we
literally watched from Poseidon's eyes
as he is ravaged by Kratos culminating
in thumbs to the eyes just blinding him
I wonder if he lost his contact lenses
during this well I suppose he should
have kept a closer eye on them sorry
about that when it couldn't have been
any cornea could it - make sure he's a
goner Kratos then snaps his neck and he
falls back into the ocean we're a tiny
tidal wave just so happens to kill
thousands of innocent people
Prometheus was an unlucky chap sentenced
to be consumed by a bird every day for
eternity all because he stole a little
fire Ghost of Sparta release me from my
torment
well Kratos decides to help him out and
to do this he burns him alive
I do that for any of my friends wouldn't
you as the saying goes give a man fire
he'll be warm for an evening but set a
man on fire and he'll be warm for the
rest of his life you did the right thing
traitor
you'll have read Prometheus from the
torment of the gods
remember Gaea from earlier yeah the big
primordial girl well news has spread
that Kratos killed her and Chronos is
here for revenge
first crushing Kratos between his
fingers
nope that didn't work then eating him
nope that didn't work either
well this Titan has definitely not
anticipated Kratos his skill and gets
what he deserves a brand new piercing
things get worse for Chronos and he's
known
that reminds me did you hear about the
jive with diarrhea he didn't well it's
all over town I don't think there's any
arguing here but the greatest murder of
Kratos his killings breathes has to be
that of Helios in God of War three
battling the personification of the Sun
sounds like a difficult fight to win but
Kratos systematically breaks down Helios
and his guards and inches towards his
victim this reminds me of the time I
stayed up all night trying to find the
Sun then it dawned on me anyway when
Kratos is close enough to Helios he
shows him his new shoes before the
greatest and most disgusting god of war
moment happens wait wait
that is where you are
[Music]
Kratos maybe a shady character but now
it's his time in the Sun so that's it
that's eight golden warm moments which
can't be unseen would your murder list
be any different from mine please let me
know your thoughts and which was the
best boss fight we've ever had in the
series and who do you think will be
fighting in the next God of War
installment please share your thoughts
below I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
I'll see you next time